you
hi everyone is Jerry I'm on leeches org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game against Flinx ttan I don't think
this is a well probably probably our
first time playing classical
so let's see I guess we'll start with C
for C with black throws at us c5
ISA 'qs g6e six it is
okay
well what haven't I done yet let's try
let's try Knight c3 maybe we could go in
for a classical variation of the
nimzo-indian yeah why not okay just
prepared to maintain my structure on the
queenside i don't want to work with CC
pawns the drawback of course is that I'm
neglecting
kingside development
and also well I'm dude pulling my queen
very early so I could go right in for
just a three you know let's do it they
have to give up the bishop hair as
otherwise I just get a free move right
in the center efore strong pawn Center
so I'm acquiring a long term advantage
in that of the bishop pair but the cost
is development and I'm not too familiar
with this line I mean I've seen it
before
v5 move so
let's see how to how to meet this it's
not just a free pond they're going to be
getting some activity I think I'm
supposed to take it and then go from
there let's do it
and I may let's see what they do
okay c6 now this is where I could just
go no further with capturing as
capturing is going to help out with
their development so right around this
point I'm just thinking
get kingside development in so how
exactly to do this one thing I'm
questioning is do I have time to deploy
my bishop outside the pawn chain before
III
what I can expect is
a quick Bishop to b7 and so I think I'm
going to want to have knight on f3 let's
say Knight f3 C takes B III Bishop d7
Bishop e2 to defend my knight
my queen will soon have to move again
the C file
will be completely opened soon enough
well let's get my night here for
starters I don't think he's going to go
anywhere else
um I wonder if I could have considered
Bishop f4 now that's probably not a good
idea
a couple Knight moves to strike at my
queen
they're thinking a little bit here so
maybe
maybe they're not familiar with
me declining or white declining on
muevate I don't know just to guess
as usual I'm just kind of playing with
some general principles here as my guide
okay I can't get in efore I don't think
I want to let me let me work this out
because if I could get Bishop g5 in I'd
really like to do that
Bishop g5 Bishop b7 III Bishop takes
Knight that they really give me the two
bishops I don't think that that would be
so much of a problem
what's worth noting is that when I play
III I'm striking at b5 don't know that I
want to take it
but let's see one more to consider I'm
torn between Bishop g5 and III right now
I really feel like I could get away with
just getting this guy out first as
otherwise he's really going to struggle
isn't he
right on on III pond on B - how is he
ever getting out and about I'm not up
any material
how many more moves does black need
three more before they're fully
developed one two three
there'll be a mover to ahead because
I'll be having to move my queen I think
I'm going to go with this you know and
if questioned I don't know if I want to
get pushed around maybe cross that road
when we get to it so let's see
I guess night here is a move maybe some
fork I take their queen they take mine
I'll see still running with the two
bishops
I'm just looking at e3 Bishop e2
kingside Castle of course
where's this not going to go pretty sure
the bishop will be posted on the long
diagonal here's in sometimes you see
this kind of tactic play a role with the
rook being unprotected a 5 b 4 takes
takes hitting my Queen and the rook
we're a ways off from that but anyhow
let's get e3 in where they really invest
their light square bishop in order to
damage my kingside structure we're just
going to have to run with it that's the
case they have a choice here I may want
to just take that night out on f6 if
questioned with h6
because otherwise my queen could be a
bit uncomfortable like okay I'm kind of
happy to see that move it feels feels
pretty slow like almost like black
should've maybe given me this pawn
somehow and you know got some more rapid
development in
I can't say for sure
Bishop e2 is the most conservative just
eliminating any possibility for black to
damage my kingside structure two options
I think I want to go to e2 this is a
strong piece and so I may look to offset
it one day by playing my Bishop to f3 I
think I could pull that off of a bit
easier then if my Bishop was on d3 you
know something like this one day to
challenge the light square Bishop s'
let's go with Bishop e2
no fixed ponds in the position
some pawns on light squares
they have a light square bishop but
nothing fixed nothing defined just yet
if a move like d5 is played and we could
identify this Bishop is not such a great
piece but we're not quite there this may
be an idea d6 seems pretty solid within
Knight d7
and this might this night might like to
focus in on these squares that see four
squares a pretty key square I would say
because the pawn controls it we can one
day see a heavy piece controlling it
it's one of those intersection squares
and a square that should capture our
attention
so let's see what fling stone is coming
up with here
and I think these maybe are all blitz or
bullet games that we've played one Oh
time control one oh yeah I guess they're
all one''ôs well some hyper bullet okay
so knight c6 it is
there's another Avenue into c4
well I don't think I could do without
missiles should I be looking to prevent
this manoeuvre if I want to do that I
could maybe use this moment here to to
do just that with let's say b4
and I have my own ideas in mind with
maybe
pivoting on the c5 square although the
c5 squares into hole if I play be for
the c-4 square as a whole and that could
start to organize some organize their
pieces in some way where a minor piece
lands on c4
it could be quite a tricky piece because
it's the be three squares a whole you
know castles rook c8 pretty sure is
coming up soon Queen d2 Knight a5
threatening knight b3 it feels
uncomfortable
hmm yeah that feels uncomfortable I
wonder if I should be playing before
here hmm well my queen is hanging if I
do that and so this this might actually
be a move then be 494 Bishop takes Queen
Knight takes Queen my bishops under fire
and I'm not even threatening to take the
knight
yeah probably can't be playing before
here hmm
well if I can't play
I'm probably just going to have to
castle yep let's castle also you know
maybe I'm a bit mistaken here about rook
c8
Queen d2 and Knight a5 because this
might be a moment for me to
take advantage of the the queen being
overloaded she currently has a
responsibility pretty much has a
responsibility to be there to recapture
on Bishop takes Knight otherwise a
messed up King side structure for black
so yes rook c8
Queen d2 I am defended by my knight
Queen d2 Knight a5 Bishop takes Knight
okay let's get out of the line of fire
there is this move
you know she does not belong on an open
file
h6 is probably the move here flight
square throws a punch
and I don't know if I do well to
maintain the pin in this case h6 Bishop
h4 g5 bishop g3 94 my queen as it is is
already pretty you know she's pretty
short on squares you know I can't go to
any of these I don't want to go back
here so it's like one of these two for
my queen
I guess I could have considered queen d3
but that just didn't feel right because
I wanted to keep this I want to keep my
eyes open for this
I think I'm just going to take the night
if h6 is played I help the Queen to
develop they have a flight square
but I'm not having to worry about the
night getting it to c4 by way of a five
at least
eventually this night we'll have to find
a new square as otherwise you know he's
placing a blindfold over two pieces as
it is right now so the rook and Bishop
can't really see the world until he
finds a new post what might his post bh6
Bishop takes Queen takes let's say I go
to the C file
nyeeehhh seven into here I don't know
feels a little bit like an awkward piece
I wonder if black is having some regret
with his post to seat six I was
referencing maybe D six night here stays
out of the Bishop's way stays out of the
rooks way and connects Knights
you know if you could imagine that the
Knights were connected right here and
then my Bishop was questioned on Bishop
takes Knight there's Knight takes and
then I'm having to maybe work around a
night camping out on e4 it's a different
approach
there was some flexibility I guess we
could say with blacks Queen night
I'm not sure what other move here there
is for black
would they really go in for this Bishop
takes pawn takes and say that I really
can't make use of the damaged structure
well okay well this limits my replies
here hmm
I guess the Queen's are going to have to
come off huh yep pretty pretty forest
here Knight takes Knight wits check so
at least they got rid of my dark square
bishop that's what they accomplished
with this sequence so now we're
officially in an endgame where my knight
is a little bit closer to getting into
the c5 square which still is not yet a
hole I'd really like to play this
position where I keep my opponent you
know I want to somehow play against this
LightSquared Bishop I could have a you
know a bishop for Knight exchange and
there'd be some hole within the black
position like on c5 I'd really like to
go in for something like that but first
things first we have an open C file
there is only one open file
we will need to occupy it
and the big question question that often
comes about which rook should occupy
that file
probably the F rook because I have some
idea
of my king drifting towards the Queen
side
we could see both rooks exchanged a
knight and Bishop specific endgame is
not long off
I won't be capturing I don't have a
minor piece supporting a rook on c1 so I
just have to keep the tension or is this
not going to go nine eighty five could
be kicked I have enough control over c4
most sensitive point in my position is
this is what I consider at least the
most sensitive point in my position c4
to be careful of g2 if I'm trying to do
this sniper bishop
I was pointing out c5 not being a whole
d6 as a whole I don't know I can get
there successfully though this is
tactically flawed 94 Knight take C
hmm a-five as a whole I don't know how
great a bother a night would be on a 5
though you know the bishop backs up and
my night is kind of you know I can't
quite pass the now what test the
two-word test he doesn't have a great
follow-up
about a minute advantage for my opponent
sixteen moves in
even material
he could look to drift over with the
King that would be pretty sensible
my Bishop's unprotected to be on the
lookout for tactics as an example of
King f8 if I just say to myself well
let's just double this is already a
problem
Brooksie 2 allows Knight takes pawn and
on rook takes rook there's an in-between
move Knight takes bishop with check so
this would be a mistake if I really want
to look to double I would have to go by
way of c3 to a defended square which is
maybe not a bad idea
you know so the king is drifting over
why not why not look to double if I'm if
I'm doubled up I could be assured of
what exactly
probably both rooks coming off right
well if I double up now I think in the
end I'll be able to force one of their
pieces to retreat on a recapture all
right rook c3 King here rooks double
let's say Knight a7 one of the pieces is
retreating on econo recapture here one
of the pieces is running in Reverse that
might be a window of opportunity for me
to occupy this long diagonal with my
bishop should the bishop be the one that
recaptures on c8
he is not playing
I think I mean I was saying I want to
get my king towards the Queen side by I
think first things first it's more
important to get the rooks functioning
before we go with these slower moves
provoking a move like d6 is good firming
I think that this is a desirable move
for blacks Oh
let's go to c3 where he is defended very
important that I go to a defended square
okay
that night doesn't have oh you know what
985 I can't play before but I don't need
to kick that night so fast
yeah I could just double
ninety-five
to see one
if the night looks to reposition by way
of a 7 and d5 hmm and the night's still
in the way of a piece right Bishop can't
see so clearly
just pointing out the king you know just
kind of walking along the first rank but
maybe f3 King f2 is better with an idea
of maybe e4 expanding in the center
forming a Pandu Oh taking away some
squares not overly excited about this
I'm a bit fearful of putting in a
structure and f3 e4 d for structured
this one here because this might be an
opportunity for black to then fix one of
my pawns on a light square with let's
say d 6 and then e5 ideally I want to
keep some good harmony between my
structure and Bishop pawns on dark hill
guard the light Knight a5 it is
let's double these are offsetting pieces
I'll be recapturing at the rook
I guess I don't have to pre move we got
increment
pretty balanced on the clock now
you
yeah it's going to be tough to make
progress
rooks most likely will be exchanged
pretty level position
yeah probably a goose egg reading by the
engines okay I could force the bishop in
Reverse can I make this night just go
backwards some I want to be careful
about weakening c4 too soon
can I make a a less committal move
well
I'm going to baby step it I'm going to
do this in King f2
I'll let them capture me and then play
rook c8 and then I'll capture I take
here I'm helping this this uh this rook
not the rook on da he starts to play if
I take so I think it's best I keep the
tension here f3 King f2
if I could get an e for and then maybe
e5 maybe I look to establish upon on e5
and fix this guy in a light square and
then we're maybe working with something
maybe this idea may the influencing
might whoa whoa whoa whoa that is
surprising I just read you say that this
is a if d6 is played this type of move
to undermine the pawn support of c5 is
maybe something but they're just looking
to cement the knight in to c4 which at
the moment is not a whole
okay well Oh another thing is I could
give this check although after King d6
what do I have probably be three here
yeah
I think I'm going to go with be three we
want to keep this night out of c4
Oh for a second I thought I blundered as
I was like if Knight takes pawn I can't
take like this but yeah again these guys
are offsetting each other so by knights
there to control b3
now this is a hole so I could look to
get here with rook c5 and from there we
could have it easily happen that the
structure changes rook takes rook pawn
takes I don't know if I want to do that
I don't know if I have the time to
really assess that structural change it
would give me a passed pawn potentially
connected passed pawn but this night
remains quite a bit of a nuisance here
on a5 I see this Knight is the more
aggressive of the two you know I don't
really want to go too far with my knight
on D - okay let's get some faster moves
in here
okay why was there some hesitation there
did I have another move hmm
I think I'm going to try to just play
within this structure because if this
pawn yeah let's take here if this pawn
takes I have a passed pawn but at the
same time I allowed this pawn to
potentially move I want to make sure
he's he's staying put
now I think I might want to go for a
role reversal here no actually what
about E 4 E 4 E 4 with E 5 ideas efore
King e3 e4 pawn takes pawn takes King
III
my opponents offering a dry don't want
to draw
I can look to do this and then kind of
weasel my knight around to get to c5
this is where he wants to be no doubt
you
I feel like I might be a bit
overextended
do this
well
this night other moves I have be form
um let's do this move no I'm gonna go
with this yeah I was thinking about you
know throwing a quick punch at h7 but he
kind of gets in the way of a king
maneuver I'm looking at a king maneuver
that I'm lying up
I don't know that I would even want to
have a piece tied down to defending upon
my bishop or Knight I mean I think the
most convenient defender of b3 at this
stage is Mike King I think this is a
fine home a king on c3 then my knight is
freed up and I can look to get them into
c5 which is a forever whole
this might be a move or if they take
here then you know they're giving me a
central majority which I don't know how
great of an asset that is in ascending
okay going down to the wire
we sure have
a lot of pieces within these 20 some
moves
can't take with the night I'd be
dropping be three they play Bishop b7 I
might just look for a space invader pawn
on up be five fixing some pawns on light
squares they may need to just take here
now they're not doing that I think
they're running into some problems now
because I have some space I have the
correct kind of harmony between Bishop
and on structure and if challenged I can
be supporting it with f4
now's my time to get my king working
this isn't a move to try and fix my pawn
on b3 on a light square my pressure here
and some pressure against them on the
clock as well
goodnight versus bad
ship situation is what I want I
definitely want to maintain the
versus two situation in the center
well it's just offset the night and
we're throwing a punch at the pond I'm
prepared to give up my bishop for the
night
whoa another locked pond let's let's not
allow this to get too locked now
well just as I say that I'm ready to
play b4 night b3 night c5 I think it's
the way to go
49 seconds
they really just try
put a complete clamp on the position
hmm
can I get into c5 without playing b4
that's what I would really like to do
don't have much time
I'd really like to hesitating on making
that move but gotta get something fast
in there well this is a blunder because
I'm hitting three things they could
easily go wrong
now I'm picking up a pond
they just drop their a6 pawn their
knights going to get into
get into c4
hmm
let's go here
yes okay let's take save my pond
probably play a little faster huh
they're going to lock it down Wow so
nothing happening on the queenside
well this allows this break the bishop
probably should have he needed to sit
now he's dead and I could give this
check and pick up the c4 upon
he's my next target
so
after them
and just mopping up some ponds now I'm
on the bishop
let's take another pond
you
and I can
to this and then my king improvement
could use this pawn to deflect the King
away
he tries to defend
scoop him up
and now what oh we have a fork
definitely be looking for the forks and
they resigned yeah
my night went into a bit of a pac-man
mode there
okay it was a tight one close close game
there I wonder if it could have been
held right around here even though I was
up upon and they're working with a
Bishop right around here suppose the
bishop doesn't leave c6 I don't think I
can get a good pawn break in
let me go into the analysis
so right here oh no no I don't want to
look at that just yet but you know if I
come over here it's black smooth let's
say oh let's just say they kind of past
with King there now if I try to do
something like this with a four takes
and then look to hunt this pawn down is
that working yeah it is working isn't it
no it's not because if I still just
making passing moves no no not a passing
move in this case this pawn I think
starts to run now if I take then he
pushes my Knight can't stop the pawn my
king must and then I'm dropping my
knight I don't know if I can get it I
don't know if there's a good pawn break
for me to kind of a crash through and in
a way my knight is kind of you know he
can't make use of these squares these 3
squares either so there's only one
Square open to them a six but where is
he going from a six here here I don't
see what that's really accomplishing I
go here the bishop backs up and the best
I could do is just return yeah it might
be tricky for me to win from here if the
bishop didn't leave from indirectly
influencing the a4 square because this
this allowed the undermining of the
structure and then these guys kind of
fall like dominoes in time
okay well it'll certainly be one to look
back on
with the engine but before I get into it
what's the opening here so it just goes
as far as saying that classical
let's request a computer analysis says a
classical variation
okay yeah I think this is fine
and I just and I didn't want to take and
help out the development so no no pretty
quiet game okay no you know what here we
have I guess we are following theory huh
some yeah okay so you are following what
here's one of the top games give Guinea
bar a of versus Vishy Anand play this a
line knight c6 okay castles rook c8
Queen d3 hmm I went Queen d2 so I guess
I guess one of the ideas that this is to
sidestep
this idea
hmm okay so we followed theory for about
a dozen rows I guess well I don't know
theory about some games at least have
been played up until this point right
here Queen d2 is something different you
know and probably for this reason
that's why queen d3 should be played to
avoid this win of the dark square bishop
which I mean as I was saying during the
game I was fine with it had h6 been
played I was going to be capturing the
night anyhow Queen d2 I don't think
there's any fancy tactics missed just
some things to sidestep like I mentioned
during the game but yeah pretty quiet
this is the this is certainly the the
one moved to question in the game
kills the bishop gives me squares to
work with us square to work with c5 it's
the main one and sure enough what soon
as I made use of that one move later I'm
picking up some material didn't have to
go down like that but just the activity
alone you know there's a lot of
different things to consider when you
have a piece in your position
they should do without d6 something much
more conservative like or they should do
without d5 something more conservative
like d6 I imagine it's better keeping a
close eye on this but they had it in
their mind to jump in and jump the night
into c4 this is a much different story
if my pawn is already committed to be
four you know and this could be this is
already a hole for black but it's not
the case right now so d5 I'm just
fighting against the move they played
taking away the c-4 square how many
pieces they have on it a ton I only need
one pawn there to stop a piece from
arriving
you know they shouldn't have gone with
that it may it's maybe still hold a bowl
but it's definitely black who's
struggling here and there they're going
all in placing pawns on light squares
they really just trying to lock down the
whole position I shouldn't have been
yeah again I I probably should have done
something different because what we saw
is that as soon as I played b4 black was
like right on that you know c4 is now a
whole and sure enough the knight is
finding a way in there so I should be a
bit more patient but I kind of
as mentioned made this move with an eye
on the clock I do have time it's such a
lock position I do have time to maneuver
you know Knight f3
II won d3 and then c5 I get in this this
square here and maybe even you know
another way to look at it and it's may
seem a bit far-fetched but you know by
having a pawn on b4 I could forget about
trying to enter with my king like this
so he kind of blocks us a specific path
into the black position this is
something black would have to kind of
weigh is a possible king invasion
it's a these type of
missions remind me of my favorite
Nintendo game Solomon's key where it's
just you really have to find like the
correct path and have a build the blocks
or put your pawns on the exact on the
correct squares and look for these
different plans anyhow I gave up that c4
square it just dropped upon here so they
have to do something different like
maybe that I don't know no they can't do
that so fast because my knight is
hitting everything my knight is hitting
really really fast here isn't he here
I'm hitting four pieces King Bishop in a
couple ponds so maybe they're already in
trouble maybe maybe b4 is okay and the
knight Knight move is off let's see
before that I think they'd have to take
some measures against Knight c5 so maybe
this Knight B 3 and then King here
Knight check and the bishop
a good job of offsetting the night it's
a really bad Bishop but at least it's
offsetting my night I'm still able to
play for something you know but it's a
much bigger struggle with still material
being balanced
even though I have the
the correct harmony again between Bishop
and pawn structure and some space I
don't know if this would be enough to
convert with so many instances of fixed
ons
I do have a pawn break here a four and
maybe with that a timely capture of a
six
hmm still big struggle they made it a
little bit easier on me as soon as I got
that pond and also when they pulled the
bishop away from the a Foursquare now I
think I'm almost certain you know plus
five see what the graph is looking like
there you have it
let's just look at one of the points
here
Yeah right around this point one pawn
advantage I don't know one point
advantage I don't think is enough Bishop
d3 is fine
b4 we'll have a look at it let's let's
put on the engine right from the
beginning don't think there's anything
missed we could see that there is
nothing missed yeah kind of zip right
through to the sending and just oh right
here d5 I would just want to look at d5
that's something that's going to show up
on the evaluation but
and we're not seeing a much a big shift
right there but d5 is d6 is better
computer likes white more as soon as dd6
is played but now I don't think you
should be giving up that c5 square so I
think d6 is is better okay
demo at d5 still holding stone slight
slight advantage for white nothing
nothing significant I guess they could
have considered a capture
and at least this bishop is now relevant
you know he's he's on up some of my
pieces as soon as d5 was played in the
game the bishop never saw the white side
of the board
that was an alternative to just take I
was very happy to get this in and I
maintain my pawn on e5 you know they
have to be really careful now
as soon as b4 is in easy to go wrong and
maybe it is just busted from here he is
coming he is hitting c5 really fast
you know still holding at 1.5 takes how
do I win this though I think the
computer would need a little bit more
time to really evaluate this okay it
doesn't like that move
why exactly king d2 is what I did
King c3 and suppose they shuffle this is
what I was questioning oh I could just
play a four straightaway so this is here
no matter what
yeah I could do this Oh which also
that's that's why they did this move
maybe because they saw I was ready to
undermine but one way or the other I'm
I'm getting this break in now okay
a four takes King takes bishop check
King here a three
I got to start running okay I mean it's
winning but it's a little bit
uncomfortable for me you know I don't I
don't even want to have to deal with
this guy being passed and at the moment
there's a bit of a wall here stopping my
king from approaching the pawn hmm but
yeah as I was played I'm getting in a
four and I don't have to worry about a
past rook pawn which is for a knight a
nightmare hmm and then I'm able to scoop
up the C pawn and everything else so a
little bit more resistance but by this
time we're both in bullet mode and you
know just pac-man from there okay well
pretty simplified one I think a couple
games back and this standard games
playlist it was quite quite a simplified
game another one here but image to pull
something out of it as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below and as always
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you